[Music]
[Applause]
adam sandler is working on a new movie
he is producing starring in hustle
netflix movie about a former basketball
recruiter tries to remake his career by
bringing back a player from overseas to
play in the nba lebron james a
co-producer among the luminaries in the
movie hustle queen latifah
ben foster love ben foster robert duvall
bobby
uh
kenny smith from tnt is in there and
mclovin also has a role and adam sandler
joins us from somewhere in philadelphia
sandman how are you today hi danny it's
so funny robert duvall called me up it
was like three in the morning
i go hey hey what's going on bobby i
can't do the movie unless i said what do
you mean unless
mclovin i need mclovin
so uh yeah that's how that happened okay
danny i miss you how are you i'm good
i'm good uh you got
you got a lot of nba players in this
movie
unbelievable yes i just shot yesterday
did a scene with doc rivers okay and uh
and
and a bunch of the sixers were in there
tobias matisse
uh seth curry
uh who else was there tyreese maxie just
all nice all nice guys and and uh today
i'm going to play
i'm going to do like this scene where
there's a pickup game and it's all these
all these and one guys are coming to
play not not nba guys but a bunch of n
one guys are coming to the park to play
it's it's been unbelievable for me and
unfortunately daddy the worst timing
ever my foot hurts
every time i go on the court i go i
can't play and all these great guys are
playing i can't even shoot
you gotta stomp
you picked up golf recently so just i
did you can play golf the rest of your
life
like this okay why don't you retire as a
basketball player after this movie
well i i i think i did i think my foot
did my foot told me i can't do it
anymore but i but i it's the only time i
sweat
oh yeah that's right that is your only
exercise
you know what i mean yeah that and and
and
holding myself up in the bedroom but
that that
that's only like a 40-second sweat
you're not even a minute man
no no no every time somebody says a
minute man i'm like how does he do it
how do you come up with the idea that
you're going to do a movie about a
basketball scout for the sixers down on
his luck
finds this great player and is going to
bring him back to the nba to somehow
reclaim his career life
by the way you're in the movie too and
so it's over the danettes and besides
mclovin you're playing yourself but um
but um
this was just total luck those guys
brought it to me they brought it to me
it was written originally
that i find a player in china
uh and and somehow uh netflix is not in
china so they were like
would you guys please make it that we
find somebody in latin america or europe
so
next thing you know i'm in my org
wait that's how that happened
yes yes yes it was originally i found a
player in china and by the way you know
what
i saw the picture where you're at the
beach and you got your shirt off and
you're getting in the water there that
was disgusting
yeah i know and i'm looking i'm flipping
through and it's like adam sandler
taking a dip and i'm going what a
humiliating moment yeah
nothing nothing gross because by the way
not only was i swimming there thinking i
was happy you know for once in my life
going oh let me jump in the
mediterranean but then
on top of that joe bessie was swimming
and he can't swim and i seriously was
watching him i was like is he about to
die out there that's what they got a
picture of him standing there with a
shirt off going my friends about to die
this is amazing you need to get a body
double
[Laughter]
by the way i saw one of the pictures i
was like it could have been a lot
there's nothing good there's nothing
good about it but there's nothing
atrocious about it
what is lebron james doing with the
movie i i guess is he co-producing this
yeah it's his company him and maverick
uh they they have a big movie company
now and they those guys called me with
the script and joe roth and uh and they
all uh
it was great it was a really cool script
i play a scout i get to
play kind of a guy who's been in the
league a long time getting pushed around
and not not really getting any traction
uh but but loves it he wants to coach
one day and robert duvall owns the team
and i've been scouting for years and
duvall
finally says uh you know what we're
gonna make your assistant coach this
year and he and he passes away and his
son
uh that ben foster's playing takes over
the team and doesn't like me so he gets
me back on the road and so when i'm on
the road i'm like if i find that one guy
like luca dirk or somebody like that
caliber that you can't deny me on that
what i've done for the team and they'll
give me a shot
and i find uh juancho fernand gomez
who's just
the greatest
i can't tell you danny he acts so much
better than me and every scene that's
like god damn it this guy's falling
crying in the middle of scenes doing the
right thing just
every joke he says i'm like he said it
smoother than i would have and he's an
nba player
like you're getting acted by an nba
player
destroying me at 6 10 staring looking
down at me going no no no that's not how
you do it let me show you
and he's a great guy and i got to meet
his family in spain and his brother
willie is a great guy
oh by the way the whole spanish olympic
team was in the movie too a lot of the
guys uh
when i was in spain
what happens is i find him at a kind of
like a rucker park of spain
kind of uh game and he's dominating out
there and i say hey man you know i go
and meet him and
tell him what i do and he
doesn't speak english well so he thinks
i'm lying and i get him to
come practice with me the next day with
with the spanish olympic team so it's
just to show him that i'm legitimate and
then i bring him over to america
we're talking adam sandler and the new
movie that he's shooting now it's called
hustle and it'll be on netflix but
you're also did you did you finish the
sean payton movie
that's done that looks that looks great
that's kevin james and he's he and my my
wife's brother wrote it and uh kevin
james plays sean payton and this is the
year that he gets suspended by the
commissioner and the movie is about him
coaching his son in high school
well shawn's daughter
megan did this incredible short
on um
on sean and it was about you know i
don't even know maybe 10 minutes long
about what happened that year when sean
didn't play
didn't coach the team and wasn't allowed
to hang out at the nba nfl he went home
and coached his son's pop warner team or
i said or you know youth team
and um
and got closer with us his boy because
they were hanging out and then he said
it was the best year of his life
with football so i i called those guys
up i said that that would be an
incredible movie and
anyway sean was cool i said yeah let's
do it and then uh my wife's brother
chris wrote it with his buddy and uh
sean was cool enough to do it and then
we told kevin james about it and he said
each not a problem he'll lose three to
four pounds if we want to film and he
did it no but kevin's great in the movie
play sean
it's awesome and sean's in in the movie
at the end
and uh
you're in the movie and everybody's in
the movie uh sandman will text me
sometimes at odd hours whether you're in
hawaii or you're in spain like you don't
live a movie star
lifestyle
well i i i work too much i work too much
in fact i got home last night from
working all day with those with those
the sixers and i was so excited and then
i was like oh yeah i got that meeting to
i gotta do editing tonight i'm losing my
marbles a little bit but i get it pretty
i mean you saw my body in the picture
that your life's pretty good it's
there's some food being eaten yeah
uh your little league team uh got
eliminated yesterday by ohio but uh
that's a hell of a run from your your
little league team uh
those guys were and they almost won
yesterday i didn't see the whole game i
was shooting and then i went into my uh
trailer and it was on and and i saw them
coming back and they they play i mean
ohio was great but uh
new hampshire
manchester hook said we were making a
run and it was a tight game but and at
kitten right field on ohio made a great
catch
but it was they were rolling all of a
sudden but i couldn't couldn't be
happier for those guys that's a dream
when we were kids we we were like
man we got to get to williamsport that
was every kid's dream in little league
and the fact that they did it and they
beat all those teams to get there was
very proud of them okay but this is your
little league team you played on this
same team
the same exact field same park i played
my my whole youth in my dad was my coach
all my best friends were or on the uh
all-star team with with me uh
and those were the best
springs and summers of our lives and
then we played pretty well in our
tournament we i think we got pretty far
into the state
championship and then we lost i'm pretty
sure if i remember correctly we played
about eight nine like we went on a run
but now like these guys these guys were
insane how good they played what
position did you play
i was a shortstop and a pitcher okay i
was pretty damn good i was pretty damn
good back then and then all of a sudden
everybody got in the babe ruth league i
noticed everyone grew four to five
inches and i was like what happened
no but literally i wasn't i was i was
good
i i saw the picture
your your front row your your dead
center front row
you got your big fro
i had a little little extra hair i
didn't know it every year it it was
different some sometimes i had the scuzz
they called the discus
when you got a crew cut sandman got a
sketch
and then then there were the days where
my mother would say let your hair grow
baby it's so beautiful
and i would look disturbing that my
father would stare at me at the table
like we got to cut that hair you look
ridiculous
were you it's so
what was yours what would be the
scouting report on this sandman
okay so i was
no no lie
they called me the vacuum i was very
smooth out and uh
i i nothing got by me at short i had a
decent arm got it the first dice and if
if in and by the way in little league
now when the
when they throw they have a double play
these guys act like that was supposed to
happen when we had a devil playing
literally we looked at each other like
did that really we did two people and
what
what happened i know but but i know that
was exciting a double play back then
these guys literally
i don't know how they got so good so
young but
and then what else was that i was good
but i had a good bat i had a good bet i
got i could i pulled it every time
never never hit anything to write to you
i pulled it every time and uh
i never knocked one out i hit the fence
one time it was a wooden
wooden like uh the signs were all over
the fence and i remember hearing boom
and i was like oh yeah defense god damn
it
well and i think i got a double it was
not even a thought of a triple but if i
would have said back then hey you can be
a professional baseball player or you
can go up and be a comedian
a baseball player would have wanted that
now the truth is danny i was laying in
bed one day it was like a saturday
afternoon and i said to my dad i might
have told you this i said to my dad he
goes what do you want to do
one year older i said
i want to be a pro baseball player he
goes
[Laughter]
mcdonough kyle mcdonough he could be a
pro baseball player he goes you're slow
and i go yeah i know i'm slow but uh i'm
not that's all you guys no you're real
you've never seen yourself run
and then you film me you fill me with
one of those super eight cameras and he
goes look at your run
you can't be a pro
that sounds like a movie
that's pretty true man he was just go he
was just looking at me like quit lying
yourself let's get to something and then
i remember when i told my dad i want to
be a comedian he was all back that up
100 but he said but you got to give
yourself
a time limit
and so if you uh if you don't make it by
the time you're 23 you come work for me
i said yeah yeah okay and then i started
doing okay i have very young and he's
like and i said do i have to work here
yet he goes no no no you're making
enough let's go keep going with that but
that was that was a fallback plan i was
going to be an electrician for my dad
you
[Laughter]
and then danny were you good at little
league i bet you were incredible uh
shortstop pitcher
me and you buddy and you had ohio
against new hampshire because that was
your team yeah and ohio won yesterday
you guys want to get
you better ice cream you make better ice
cream than me everything about you wins
you got i think a nicer house
well i got i got about six or seven
votes and every everyone dominates your
house
i asked sandman i'm like you know when
you ask somebody when you hope that
they'll invite you to their house and i
go up so
where's your home in hawaii and he gave
me like a very vague
location
it's on one of the islands
it's on one of the islands i go oh okay
all right it's not there's not a lot of
islands man you'll find it
but danny would you like to come and
golfer uh can you go golfing i would
like now that you're now that you're
picking up the sport again yes i'm
getting it getting it going guys i
almost had it i had one
not i had two good rounds on nine holes
but then i played 18 and i blew up on
both both the other nine but i had one
39 on nine and then a 37
and then i got 45s on the back and then
like a 47er my goodness gracious i had
it going do you still belong to riviera
yes
well i played there the other day that
would be nice when i come out for the
super bowl that we could go play riviera
country club
yeah but yes we'll do that but don't you
think me and you for like three four
days living in uh
like we said
yeah that time we had fun there and now
we're making a movie this could be more
fun okay but is this just you and me
i you want one i bring you two danettes
i can't have one no no no i i was going
to have fun i want famous people i i
don't want to bring the damn ass yeah
you know i'll have i'll have anderson
just kind of oh
no you kept aniston away from me when we
shot that movie you know that you did
yeah yeah you listen no i didn't i i
knew i listened she you friends blocked
me with jennifer aniston and i had i had
at all i had good intentions
you had no intention that it was good
for your family i i know your wife's a
good woman there's no way
the way you anderson walks by you with
that perfume you're just like oh man
i might have thought that but i i i
wouldn't have done that but yeah
we could get dave matthews to again and
we could go to hawaii you me dave
matthews and jennifer aniston
and you've got to tell the truth the
whole time you didn't even mention
driver you just like please introduce me
to keith urban
uh well nicole kidman wanted nothing to
do with me and and no no nobody did
nobody did well not that i did the women
didn't but uh
keith urban
yes keith wanted to talk sports and then
i think nicole was surprised that he her
husband knew who i was
and and then you know we got along
famously after that
of course um i can play guitar by the
way that keith urban unbelievable he is
smooth he can sing
could take anybody's wife away
uh one of your co-stars in the movie
hustle has a question yes mclaren yeah
adam it's mclovin there's a lot of
emails going around i could probably use
a push from you the size of my trailer
has become an issue on set
i mean i don't it doesn't need to be
huge just like does he get a double
banger
he gets he gets uh he's sharing it okay
he's sharing the trailer uh but he does
we did get him a full weight room
we got him a uh
got a nice guy on the set there's an uh
extra green room for him we got all the
candles mclovin asked for what is the
strangest thing you've ever asked for
or heard somebody ask
well i don't know
nothing nothing awful nothing i i don't
really ask for too much but but i think
maybe i do ask for too much because
sometimes
the the people stare at me like i'm a
i'm a pig
but uh
what the hell uh no nothing too bad just
wait wait rooms weight rooms i i i i
like
i like my trail is kind of open hole all
i ask for is a baseball package that's
it i said make sure you have the
baseball or the basketball package
depending on what season it is yeah or
football uh that's it all right so uh
i'll uh i'll let you know i'll be
shooting my stuff up here in the man
cave but mclovin's gonna be joining you
there in philadelphia in a couple of
weeks
it's going to be great sorry to the to
the other fellas we'll come
maybe i'll look at the script and see if
we can come up with something if they if
they want to come out no no no no i'm
still scarred from the susan sarandon
prison scene that we did
you were funny in that one man sandman
do you know that susan sarandon refused
to make eye contact with us
just because
she had no idea who we were and had no
interest in it talking to us even though
we all wanted to talk to her she had no
interest do you tell these women that
are in scenes with us to not socialize
with us
there's this energy you guys bring that
is so
so scary
that
every woman just kind of just goes nice
best i was
that's not to even look
at that i will say katie holmes
there was a twinkle in her eye
uh that next day
that was ohio that's ohio stuff yes it
was anybody from ohio like
everyone else is very nervous man
um no you're too tall and gangly they
they want you to eat more they want
shorter guys they're used to short guys
all the hollywood stars are short
what are you six six seven
uh we'll uh we'll talk to you soon and
uh my best everybody there and uh thanks
again
to all the kids in new hampshire or uh
by the way congrats to all the little
league kids who were rolling rolling out
there or even got to that tournament and
uh new hampshire manchester hooksett you
guys were awesome awesome loved watching
you and the whole town was we were all
loving you okay and danny i'll speak to
you soon thank you sandman that's uh
adam sandler and the movie is hustle be
coming out on netflix take a break phone
calls coming up after this